We start by multiplying 1 and negative 12, the coefficient of the x squared
term, and our constant term. That gives us the top number. Negative 4 is with
the x term, so this goes in the bottom of our number puzzle. Here are the factor
pairs for negative 12. I know one of the numbers needs to be negative in each of
the pairs since a negative times a positive is a negative. We want to find the
factor pair that sums to negative 4. That must be this pair, 2 and negative 6.
Next we use our factor pair to rewrite the x term. We'll have x squared plus 2x
plus negative 6x minus 12. I'm just showing you where these two factors come
from in our number puzzle. But it's best to write this part as negative 6x. We
can use factoring by grouping to remove an x from the first two terms, and a
negative 6 from the last two terms. I need to remove a negative 6 from both
these terms, so I wind up with x plus 2 for both of these parenthesis. Remember
to distribute, to always have a quick check, to make sure you're doing the step
right. We can factor one last time to get x minus 6 times x plus 2, our
completely factored form.